[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo los saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
mientras avanza el segundo mes de la
invasión rusa a ucrania el flujo de
personas que huyen de la guerra no para
los 4 millones de refugiados que estimo
acnur por el conflicto ya fueron
superados y a diario esa cifra es cada
vez mayor ante tal éxodo el desafío está
en los pasos fronterizos al otro lado de
ucrania es vital el trabajo de los
voluntarios que apoyan el proceso de
recepción sin embargo el cansancio el
frío extremo y los testimonios por la
guerra muchas veces lo superan pero al
final lo importante está por encima de
la fatiga ahora piden apoyo a la
comunidad internacional para poder
continuar con su labor veamos
desde finales de febrero este cruce
fronterizo ha sido testigo del
desplazamiento por la guerra médica en
polonia es el punto de llegada para
estas personas que huyen de los
bombardeos sin entender aún en qué
momento tuvieron que abandonar ucrania
esta es una guerra de asesinatos de
mucha sangre muchos civiles se están
muriendo
no entiendo por qué esto es posible en
el siglo 21 y porque nadie puede
detenerlo
al otro lado de la frontera las puertas
están abiertas y encuentran el apoyo
necesario para continuar su viaje o
pedir asilo pero con el pasar de los
días las cosas se ponen difíciles para
los voluntarios en este lugar
todos estamos muy muy cansados porque en
realidad las ong que por supuesto se han
visto superadas por los acontecimientos
no están aquí en absoluto o solo en una
pequeña parte
entonces se sienten solos los
suministros comienzan a escasear y las
fuerzas disminuyen algo que impactará en
la recepción de los refugiados en este
momento a pesar de que tenemos muchas
donaciones definitivamente existe la
posibilidad de que esto se desvanezca de
hecho conocí a otro médico que dirigió
un centro de refugiados en jaroslaw y
tiene pocos suministros de medicamentos
estamos tratando de ayudarlos por lo que
acnur pide más apoyo de la comunidad
internacional para garantizar la ayuda
de estas organizaciones pequeñas que
llegaron hasta la frontera con el único
objetivo de ayudar
suele haber mucha atención al principio
de una emergencia cuando se ven esos
movimientos que empiezan a producirse
cuando la situación es fluida y volátil
pero a medida que esas crisis se
prolongan es realmente importante que
ese interés esa ayuda y ese apoyo se
mantengan es decir es realmente
importante porque eso no significa que
las necesidades sean menores simplemente
se prolongan y requieren una respuesta
más sólida y sostenida la incansable
recepción de refugiados no solo los
agota físicamente sus historias de
guerra también les añade una carga
mental pero pese a todo los voluntarios
no quieren retirarse del terreno
y por el contrario son cada vez más los
voluntarios que llegan a polonia y no
todos son apoyo de la misma forma un
pianista por ejemplo cambio las salas de
conciertos por escenarios que necesitan
sonidos para la paz el músico llegó con
su instrumento a polonia para brindar
algo de alivio a los refugiados que
ingresan al país veamos de quién se
trata en el siguiente informe
como un reloj todos los días a las 4 de
la tarde david saca su piano en el cruce
fronterizo de médica en polonia su
música saluda a los refugiados a medida
que llegan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es muy importante que yo esté aquí todos
los días es un gesto simbólico yo
necesito darles fuerzas y ayudar a todos
aquí tengo listas tres canciones
ucranianas que puedo tocar que aprendí
aquí en médica
quieres oír un poco
[Música]
bueno
david construyó el mismo su piano
portátil el músico alemán ha tocado en
la plaza maidán de ucrania y en la plaza
taksim de estambul así como frente al
bataclán tras los atentados de parís de
2015 él utiliza la música para promover
la paz una persona que no ha ocurrido
esa idea es persona que tiene corazón
porque la música es muy sentimental y yo
creo que es un gran apoyo para la gente
que deja sus casas
mientras la vida recoge nuevas canciones
en cada país al que visita tiene algunos
viejos clásicos a los que felizmente
regresa
en la memoria de un refugiado siempre
quedará el recuerdo de quienes les
brindaron ayuda durante su proceso de
desplazamiento la incertidumbre de
cruzar las fronteras tiene algo de
alivio al encontrar una guía en un país
desconocido y el dato de migración de la
semana el 23 de mayo es la fecha que
marcará el fin del polémico título 42 en
eeuu una medida del gobierno throne que
continuó durante la administración by
the end y que le permitía a las
autoridades migratorias la deportación
en caliente de las personas que llegaban
a las fronteras bajo el argumento de la
pandemia de kobe 19 más de 17 millones
de migrantes fueron expulsados bajo esta
medida
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]